Une bonne glace, ça va faire du bien
par cette chaleur.
Ça fait mal à la tête !
Je sais, ça jette un froid.
Aujourd'hui, je vous explique tout ça.
L'histoire de ce dessert.
Et pourquoi la glace nous fait
parfois mal à la tête.
Vanille, chocolat, fraise, citron, nougat.
En 2020, les Français ont consommé
172.000 tonnes de glace,
mais nous sommes loin derrière nos voisins
du nord, l'Estonie, la Finlande,
la Lituanie, la Norvège ou la Belgique
qui, bon an mal an,
arrivent dans le top
5 des plus gros mangeurs de glace.
Et notre goût pour ce dessert
ne date pas d'hier.
Allez ! Retour à L'âge de glace !
N'exagérons rien.
Les tout premiers desserts glacés
remonteraient au moins
à l'Antiquité, d'après la légende,
à la cour d'Alexandre le Grand.
On se régalait de macédoine,
de fruits mélangés
à du miel et refroidis avec de la neige.
À Rome, l'empereur Néron,
lui, se faisait livrer
de la neige des Alpes
pour la mélanger à du vin et du miel.
Mais la véritable histoire de la glace
commence au 13e siècle avec Marco Polo.
Il ramène en Italie la technique mise au point
par les Chinois pour fabriquer des sorbets.
Leur secret ?
Refroidir artificiellement le récipient
contenant les ingrédients
avec un mélange de neige et de salpêtre.
Trois siècles plus tard, un autre Italien, le bien nommé Bernardo Buontalenti est le premier à intégrer du lait dans la recette.
C'est ce qui va donner naissance
à la crème glacée, avec ce côté crémeux
qu'on aime encore aujourd'hui
et que les Français vont découvrir
grâce à Catherine de Médicis,
qui glisse la recette dans son trousseau
lorsqu'elle traverse les Alpes
pour épouser Henri 2 en 1533.
Ce dessert devient alors si populaire
chez les aristocrates français
qu'un grand nombre d'entre eux
se font construire à côté de leur château
des glacières, des réservoirs
creusés dans le sol
et maçonné, conçus pour y conserver
de la glace toute l'année.
Ce n'est pas fini.
La crème glacée reste longtemps
une gourmandise réservée à l'élite.
Elle se popularise seulement à partir
du vingtième siècle avec
les progrès techniques
permettant de produire du froid
plus facilement et grâce
à un petit coup de pouce du hasard.
Durant l'hiver 1905, Frank Epperson,
un jeune Américain de 11 ans,
oublie son verre de soda avec un agitateur
devant la porte de sa maison.
Le lendemain, après une nuit très froide,
il découvre que sa boisson a gelé.
Le résultat est délicieux.
Il vient d'inventer le bâtonnet glacé.
La suite? Dans la cuisine.
Glace, glace à l'eau, glace au lait, glace aux oeufs, crème glacée,
glace aux fruits, sorbet, sorbet plein fruit.
Il existe huit grands types de glaces
reconnues aujourd'hui par la profession.
Et si les parfums à la vanille
ou à la fraise sont les plus populaires,
ça n'empêche pas les glaciers du monde
entier de rivaliser d'imagination
pour mettre au point de nouvelles saveurs,
parfois très étonnantes.
Glace au homard,
au foie gras, au piment, à la pizza.
Une bonne glace camembert,
ça vous dit ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Mais écoute plutôt ça : en Angleterre,
un glacier a eu l'idée lumineuse d'ajouter
une protéine extraite de Méduse
dans de la crème glacée.
Résultat : sa crème devient luminescente
quand on commence à la lécher.
Allez, un autre exemple :
àDubaï, le Scoopi Café
propose une coupe Black Diamond,
une glace à base de vanille de Madagascar
et de safran iranien,
agrémenté de fines tranches
de truffes italiennes et de paillettes
d'or comestible 23 carats,
le tout servi dans une coupelle Versace
que l'on emporte après dégustation,
le prix de cette petite merveille ?
Plus de 700 euros.
700 euros !
Ça fait mal !
Au porte monnaie.
Non à la tête !
Ça, c'est ce qui arrive
quand on avale sa glace trop vite.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la céphalée
de la crème glacée.
Je vous mets tout de suite au parfum.
Les scientifiques ne savent pas très bien
expliquer ce phénomène.
Selon une hypothèse,
quand on avale un gros morceau de glace,
la température au fond de la bouche
baisse brutalement.
Au contact du froid, deux artères situées dans cette région :
l'artère carotide et l'artère cérébrale
antérieure qui alimente le cerveau,
se contractent avant de se dilater.
La contraction des vaisseaux,
puis leur dilatation au niveau du palais
engendrerait une douleur
que l'on assimile au mal de tête.
Le nerf trijumeau,
qui intervient notamment
dans la transmission des informations
perçues au niveau de la face,
serait impliquée dans la transmission
de ce message de douleur.
Il pourrait s'agir de ce que l'on appelle
une douleur projetée.
Le problème se pose au niveau du palais
et c'est la tête, le front qui a mal
Oh les boules !
Pas de panique, ce mal de tête reste
sans gravité et il ne dure pas plus de 20 à 30 secondes.
Alors pour éviter le phénomène.
Il suffit tout simplement d'avaler
de petites bouchées,
de prendre le temps
de laisser fondre la glace sur la langue
et de faire des petites pauses
entre deux cuillères.
Cela évite une baisse trop brutale
de la température au fond de la gorge.
Et maintenant, un petit truc pour réussir
à confectionner de jolies coupes.
Je sors le bac de glace du congélateur
et je le laisse environ
une quinzaine de minutes au réfrigérateur
pour que la température de la glace
remonte un peu,
idéalement à -9°C.
J'utilise ensuite
ce que l'on appelle une cuillère portionneuse
à glace en inox comme celle-ci
et pourvue d'une partie mobile
qui permet de dégager la boule de glace.
Je commence par tremper
la cuillère dans de l'eau chaude,
puis je l'essuie, car
l'eau chaude ferait fondre
la crème glacée à son contact.
J'utilise ensuite ma cuillère
pour racler la surface de la crème glacée
en allant toujours vers l'avant
jusqu'à former une jolie boule.
Et voilà ! Pas mal.
Et vous, comment aimez vous la glace?
Quel parfum ? Vous les préférez
en coupe, en cornet, en bâtonnets,
avec de la crème chantilly
et du chocolat fondu par-dessus?
N'hésitez pas à partager vos goûts
et vos topings préférés en commentaire.
Allez ! À bientôt les épicurieux,
et bonne dégustation !